you
hi everyone it's Jerry amount Ches calm
and I just got paired up playing a
five-o game let's try a form and see
what we get okay
all right well let's try something a
little bit different normally I go
straight in for a pawn duo but I'm just
gonna bring the two knights out straight
away and let's see if they give up the
bishop hair or maintain the pin No
okay so we're quickly arriving at an
imbalanced position two bishops for me
and black with a perfect structure
I think I'm wanting to start with just
d3 you know and probably g3 and get the
light square Bishop on the long diagonal
yeah let's do that
unbusy forum planning Bishop d2 so let's
just follow through an idea for me can
be to relocate my queen
Queeny - and then get my f-pawn
contributing I think I like this idea
she did her job recapturing so now let's
get this guy rolling at any moment my
night could be pushed but I'd be fine
with that I'll go back home and then
reroute by way of D - okay how to
recapture I take with upon this move
this might be a sensitive square take
spontex I think I want to keep this
diagonal open for my Bishop so I have a
fine structure as well and I think it
really matters how I recapture I guess
I'll go with the Queen she'll have more
options once questioned although of the
options she has probably Queenie - still
so it's pretty solid for both sides I'd
like to see this structure flinch some
and so maybe I can provoke some
weaknesses a-four a-five if they play a
six I have one pawn restricting - so I
think I'm soon gaining something at any
moment now I can make this structure
flinch with a six this can be a future
target I probably have to pick up the
speed here this guy's flying just poking
around a little bit okay they're having
none of that I think I'm going to stop
any c4 break yeah okay
I may need to get rid of that night hmm
yeah there's maybe some issue here with
the night on b4 hmm yeah I'm starting to
see that that night might be a problem
huh decisions I feel like the bishop
pair isn't so strong in this position I
found that has good pieces hmm yeah all
right I think he's going to be too
invasive on the be Foursquare h3 is soon
going to be hip I wonder how it should
be defending it okay now they're taking
with the Queen huh I wasn't expecting
that
okay well how about we start with this
to be mindful that h3 is unprotected
he's not doing anything just yet
rookie one maybe move my bishop and
offer a queen exchange another idea
where exactly to go with the bishop
probably here going to d2 it's an
unprotected square so I'm just tying up
Queenie for maybe rook e1 Queenie four
very slow position they don't have a
flight square just yet I should probably
get this in right now rook e1 Bishop c3
is a bit annoying definitely taking with
the rook on Queen takes Queen they could
still go for b5 and then look for a c4
break let's get this guy in potentially
fixing one of these guys on a dark
square but you know let's get this guy
working maybe King f1 rookie to cover my
base point my opponents offering me a
draw I'm gonna play on that's not to say
that I have a bet
position or anything but I don't know I
don't like draws on a play for something
here I was tempted to play King f1 but
that means my queen can never be pulled
out for this diagonal anymore because of
Queen h1 mate at least now I could
consider Bishop here stuff maybe maybe
even right now yeah I guess we're gonna
have a heavy piece ending well we'll see
what black does here okay are they going
to exchange ok my King needs to get
towards the center ASAP
I have good rook activity unruhe d4 I
don't want to take because that exposes
my c2 pond and I don't want to take
another rook either because mm-hmm let's
go here I may be helping out f-5e for I
don't want to take the rook because it's
helpful with this pawn break I want to
make sure that that isn't happening so
easily so Kings a contributor now um I
feel that he's more flexible on a1 maybe
my king should be on c3
now for me I wonder what I should know
this is I don't have any increment here
and forgetting 500 minute okay I think I
want my rook back here yeah I got to go
faster I guess pawn push yep maybe
before these two pawns in a way are
restricting these two
so King here I could look to infiltrate
there's also this move if b5 takes I
could do this the rook would be
unprotected exactly what I was saying
here is this a1 King and pawn ending
I believe it is yeah I'll have a 2
versus 1 and as mentioned these two
restrict these three because of these
gaps
let's first take rip takes is a loss
King and pawn ending I'm pretty sure
whoa okay I should be winning this yeah
I think I should be winning this forty
seconds not here because of this one two
three four five six seven eight nine
thirty seconds one two three four five
knots too fast
c3 King here I push actually no best is
here leave these guys sitting and next
up I'm getting to f4 21 seconds to do it
and push I'll just take I could go with
the connected past pawn but taking is
good enough doubled and isolated but
they're going to distract the King away
from this side of the board and I'm able
to enter here next
one King and pawn ending watch out for
any sneaky c4 stuff he's gonna have to
go after him sometime and get this guy
yeah we'll get this one first 12 seconds
and I'll just push my Knight pawn and
keep my H pawn around as my tempo guy
move him just to get the opposition back
okay well this will be simple enough
maybe get two queens to make it simple
plenty of time
no stalemates and I just want to make
sure my Queens are hitting with check
and then I could pre move it out dream
of this one out now there we go
plenty of time to do that it was really
nothing position the whole while my
opponent certainly should not have gone
into the King and pawn ending yeah I had
the bishops but as mentioned from the
structure I didn't think it was a good I
didn't add anything having the bishops
was anything so great so let's let's go
through it here before I have a look at
it with the computer
as mentioned solid structure for black
I'm just getting it on the main diagonal
it's not a an open diagonal just yet but
I don't know I think that's where he
belongs
castles I never quite got my F on
working maybe maybe here I should be
taking with upon I don't know this is
probably
mmm the big well let's say any important
moment because it's a it's a shift with
the structure so if I could make this
capture and then be assured I could get
in a five I'll definitely be capturing
with upon but can I be sure I can get my
pawn there I don't think so I think
black responds well by playing e5 he's
kind of a not-so-great piece and
moreover this night while developed
isn't so great
his pawn boxes him out very nicely I'd
have to look for repositioning type Mo's
and maybe I maybe I actually could go
and for this type of idea 91
into III and then maybe I up f5 because
this is one of the drawbacks is enough
if black is going to stop this advance
by playing e5 they we can f5 in fi by
the way is uh
hmm well a square that you could
certainly watch over with upon but it's
not without some drawbacks something I
could maybe take advantage of also the
night can kind of shift gears maybe even
drop in to see for my concern during the
game I believe I referenced that this is
a sensitive point he's a yeah I
referenced that this is a sensitive
point with e5 and also just noting it
now my knight isn't a good piece either
so I should probably look to reposition
him since he's not so well placed on c3
and at the same time I'm preparing to
cover d4 should there be any type of
Knight reposition jumping into d4 I have
c3 to watch over that yeah this could
have been an idea again he's blocked in
but I could kind of work around it hmm
because as it was played when I captured
with the piece I don't think I really
have anything I tried to put a dent in
this structure by running the a pawn but
it really didn't work out
they have good pieces and still there
with a fine structure if I'm playing a
six its b6 I could hope for one day you
know maybe I get this guy and he's a
very fast past pawn but that really
feels like it's a long way off and also
by running my a pond like this I
weakened b4 and this plays a role with
my decision in the game to take out the
knight as otherwise he's posting up on
b4 and continually putting pressure on
c2 and the implications of that well
what does that mean it means I haven't
known after defend c24 forever
with a piece and I didn't want that so
I'm trying to avoid the situation in
other words where my opponent is
applying pressure to one of the one of
my pawns and I don't want to be tied
down to its defense that's one of my
pieces so that's why I took him out and
I think blacks should be recapturing at
the pond because then it justifies this
rook position they're one step closer to
playing c4 and trying to create some
target within my queen side structure
but taking that the queen I think it's
pretty level and I could probably do
without h3 I I think in the game I was
just doing this to get it to a protected
square but I should really hold off
since I had the dark square bishop on
putting my pawn on a dark square this
was this was a poor choice this is
unnecessary yeah I shouldn't have played
h4 that's a nothing
poor poor decision once we got here it
should is probably going to be reading
level for the whole way through
yeah I don't I don't know maybe maybe
our five is a little bit off because
notice that how that factored into the
final king upon ending the weakness on
g5 the whole on GFI we can say f5
creates these two weaknesses I get f4
I'm controlling these two weaknesses
they get an e5 but even so there's this
probably still level but you can't go
with the rook exchange here like at this
point you have to take with the pawn
yeah I'm certain of that we'll double
check with the computer you know I still
feel it and I'm the more active side I
have an Avenue into blacks position and
in fact why am I not going straight in
for that right now I could be doing this
so maybe maybe b5 is the final I don't
know probably shouldn't be going with b5
maybe I don't know black might have to
just sit and wait maintain King position
don't let me sneak in and don't go for
this b5 break very tempting to try and
rattle my rook position and maybe one
day look for c4 but that's a that's a
bit of a stretch I think at least so
King and pawn ending is just one I'm not
I'm way too slow if I try to do this
stuff he's got four well I guess not way
too slow but they're blacks queening
first it's unnecessary you don't really
have to calculate just maintain this
you're king over improve the King as
much as you can and then start running
with these guys eventually kick the king
away well have a look we could look at
it with the computer I don't think
there'll be too many great suggestions
but let's have a look at it still ok
stockfish let us see what we get here
caro-kann two nights mm-hmm doesn't like
g3 you hear that with g3 anything is
playable around here the two bishops hmm
okay no great shifts let me back up for
a moment
why did it want to do instead of g3 just
Queen g3 yeah that's the idea behind
this opposed okay it's just to have some
influence on g7 to make a king side
development a little bit more tricky
okay I can see that got it
it's another idea queen g3 instead of g3
I get him on the long diagonal as we're
seeing here pretty level let's have a
look at pawn takes yeah it's still even
I thought e5 and then wants to go at
rook d1 now it's popping up 91 okay so
that is an idea this Knight maneuver I
was referring to on in reply to e5 and
then takes Queen takes or Bishop takes
just a level position I don't know I
really can't add some I think I've
voiced everything I could
yeah b3 not so hot huh hmm a little bit
of a shift there and then d5 what does
it want to do Rick FD once of host still
95 Bishop d2 9 here
bishop c3 mm-hmm well that's interesting
so allowing the knight to keep pressure
he
you're my queen us to watch over this
bit uncomfortable for me I know it's
saying a slight advantage that's point
two but yeah it's a bit it's a bit
awkward to be in this state defensive
role for the Queen so I took the night
out nothing significant here with the
evaluation still nothing significant
again I would do without h4
you know level level level and the level
until what point let's see I thought
that this would be the case okay it
doesn't like f5 okay just hold your
ground black and just hold ground not
not make that pawn push now create the
weaknesses the gaps on g5 and u5 a
little something's giving away but not
giving away but nothing decisive c4 hmm
c4 with d4 okay now this is interesting
because c4 with d4 means that they will
struggle to get this majority notice how
once again have a situation where my
smaller group of pawns are restricting
their larger group due to the gaps that
are present within black structure in
the game it was seen as the h4 and g3
structure restricting these three but in
a similar way we have now these three
pawns restricting four and what that
means is this mobile healthy perfectly
healthy majority over here can get
rolling a little by little and also my
king position as well right in the game
it was blacks king who was in the better
position now it's the white king who's
in a better position and they can't get
rid of this backward pawn that's
interesting okay so c4 was a move here
and if I'm to just try and get in into
my like what was my thinking what maybe
like it's a move I see you know it's
it's it's a checking move but what what
is it that kept me from playing that
it's it's the weakness that I give up on
d4 but I could I could play d4 as a
follow up and this isn't so much of a
weakness my d3 pawn I'm exchanging alpha
an unhealthy pawn for
are pretty strong pawn on c5 hmm
interesting
oh well also the computer isn't saying
to capture here I just made that right
away but I guess this is the point where
we both do well to maintain the tension
nevertheless c4 is something I should
have given more consideration to okay
for instead still not decisive rook c4
wants to go it's b6 now it's losing b5
is the losing move uh-huh not because of
captures I could take on c5 that's that
that would be a nice tactic yeah I could
take here within the follow up e-excuse
me d4 and similar to the game this is a1
King and pawn ending these guys offset
it's once again a two versus one in my
King can enter over here
ah that would have been nice you know I
missed this little this little trick
take on c5 with d4 this isn't winning
capturing on v6 however a couple moves
later it is takes rook e6 taking what
the rook is now lost so I was mistaken
to think right around this point the
rook had to just kind of shuffle no okay
cuz this this tactic is still here
yeah b6 v6 is a better move here to to
stop that little tactical idea that's
interesting yeah that's interesting
should I should have had my eye open for
this little detail winning the King and
pawn ending but once I got here black
definitely had to keep the rooks on but
didn't and it's just a one King and pawn
ending yeah he's diverted away and the
pawns pushed through okay well
interesting game was the caro-kann two
Knights very quiet early going but uh
turned it in something later on in the
rook ending anyhow as usual feel free to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
take care bye